[Music]  for the spicy sauce slice and Chavez of  garlic next dried chilies great for  keeping the covers at a hit of heat on  demand  [Music]  then add the anchovy oil to a hot pan  and fry the chopped ingredients  [Music]  add half cherry tomatoes chopped black  olives and salted capers cook to combine  the flavors  in a separate pan ball dry spaghetti  another great store cupboard staple when  the pasta is tender but still firm drain  add to the sauce with a splash of the  water it's full of starch which gives a  great silky consistency  then season with pepper and tapas basil  packed with big bold flavors and ready  in under 20 minutes  pasta with tomatoes and cherry and  chilies Oh fish smell different the  longer it's around the more fish it will  smell bring up to the ball could infuse  the broth and make it a bit more  fragrant kaffir lime leaf is pre  lemonade in size the miso broth